talk about last week I interviewed the
daily wise Ben Shapiro on the crisis in
Israel his powerful emotional analysis
made headlines around the world 5
million people have watched that
interview so far a measure of the
enormous emotion and division this
conflict has awoken well among those
viewers was Muhammad hijab the
controversial Pro Palestine influencer
with nearly a million YouTube
subscribers of his own here's what he
had to say about it do you think P
Morgan on Fair Grounds would try and
speak to me about an issue like this or
Ben Shapiro when they know what I'm
going to come with absolutely not don't
pretend you don't know who I am you've
been watching my videos you know what
I'm about your silence is deafening and
your cowardice is apparent well Muhammad
hijab joins me now Muhammad thank you
very much for coming in uh I hadn't
actually watched your videos I have now
I've watched a few of them I'm aware
you've got a massive following you got
nearly a million YouTube subscribers
you're an influential person and you
have a lot to say about this issue
obviously so I thank you for coming in
but I'm not too cowardly to talk to you
uh I don't have a horse in this race I
think I've tried to straddle a divide of
being fair-minded with all sides I've
had all voices on the show I commend you
for that actually to be honest for
bringing me on but do realize I did
caveat that with onfair ground so let's
hope that this interview is conducted I
intend to be completely Fair sure I
promise you because all I want to get to
here is a real sense of what is going to
happen we can all look back at we can
all look back let me just we can all
look back before that PE sorry if if you
want to say fair grounds you introduced
me as a Palestinian controversial I
actually corrected myself right so I
said Pro Palestinian I meant to say Pro
palestin so why did the word
controversial come into play I think
you're controversial so are you yeah I
wouldn't so as the Ambassador why didn't
you why didn't you introduce her in that
manner I I'm happy to say that to many
people her views would be controversial
so why didn't you introduce me as the
Oxford
graduate do you want to be introduced as
that yes okay Oro for graduate go ahead
okay um no problem you can be introduced
as anything you like Frank it makes no
difference to the debate let me ask you
this where were you when you heard about
what happened on October the 7th I was
at home what was your reaction when you
heard I was actually very sickened by it
and and this is something I do want to
put on the table because I think it's
fair for people to know this in our
religion we do not believe okay as a
Muslim I am a Muslim and I do not
believe in the killing of any man woman
or children um non-combatants that is
not despite the religious teachings that
is because of the religious teachings so
terms of condemning Hamas and just
jumping straight into it I condemn not
only Hamas but any other entity okay uh
wherein it's proven that this has been
done that the killing of combatants has
been done therein I condemn any party
that does it any party that kills people
or strikes at people where there it's
more probable than not that it will hit
a civilian Target I condemn them and
that's why I condemn the IDF because
when they strike they know that it's
more probably the kns going to hit
civilian targets they know that the
majority of civilians or the majority of
people that are going to be affected are
civilians we know that from the various
operations that have been conducted we
know that because now in Gaza you find
that there is a a blockade as you know
for 17 years but also there is they're
stopping them from electricity water
which is a war crime under Geneva 4 of
the of the Geneva Convention protocol
four of the Geneva Convention so this is
something I'm surprised you didn't
actually mention to the Ambassador I did
mention I did mention it you didn't say
it's a war crime well I think it's an
arguable point with it's a war crime can
ask you now they are saying is at the
moment Israel is adamant not breaching
war crimes right it will be determined
but it will be determined whether that's
the case no no sorry
sorry mam let me just let me make a
point to you back on that I think it
surely we can agree that what happened
on October the 7th was a war crime I
mean when people are taking grandmothers
and executing them kidnapping young
children when they're when they're
killing babies in their cribs we can
agree that's War crime right okay babies
can we surely of course 100% right but
baby in the crib sorry what was the
evidence for that you don't believe that
happen sorry CNN the white house uh Sky
News which you work for all say SK I
don't work for Sky News well you your
your thing I didn't work at CNN I saw
one I saw one reporter who retracted it
because she wasn't sure about the source
it's un confirmed by the White House but
then the Daily Telegraph and the drusen
post and other sources then did publish
pictures CN indisputably showed babies
who been killed no it showed one baby
who he's been charred and that video
that picture has been put up on Twitter
and has been refuted by uh many people
saying that it's actually Ai No No that
that's completely untrue that is that is
true what's
your there's been a thorough
investigation into the claim that was
put up there by some Rogue person on
Twitter that it was AI it has been
completely disproven that picture which
was published on the telegraph is a
genuine legitimate picture what is your
Source Are you seriously arguing that
babies weren't killed no I didn't say
that what are you saying I'm saying give
me a source yeah you know full well
you've been fired from The Daily Mirror
for fake images so you know full well
about the the I didn't accept they were
faked exactly the UK government did yeah
they did uh because the UK government
just to be clear sure sure had waged in
my view an illegal war in Iraq so you're
allowed to go against the government and
I'm not allowed to go against the is
government you're of course you're
allowed to so tell me now what's the s
you seem to be making a lot of
presumptions about me Muhammad had
softball question the editor no they
weren't I put all the questions to the
Ambassador I was the editor of a Daily
Mirror when we opposed the Iraq war on
the grounds that I believed it was an
illegal War I still believe that to this
day I think it stained this country
fantastic I don't think you even knew
that I did know that right but I'm not
that's not the point I was making I was
making the point that if you allowed to
go against the government in their
classification of a an image then if you
have Pro Palestinian activists who are
saying actually we need to see a source
shouldn't they be entitled to that the
Daily Telegraph published on page three
should they be talking about the daily T
said they had independently verified
they picture Muhammad no excuse me if
you're saying that their WR no excuse me
primary source in Academia I know you've
done a journalism degree which is
frankly it's not relevant to what we're
talking about here anyway probably is to
journalism yeah no it's not to this
conflict but we academics require
primary source evidence in order to make
it the Daily Telegraph The Daily
Telegraph said they verified the picture
it's that's a second resource you may
say second resource you may say that's a
second resource well you may say you
don't think it's genuine I don't agree
with you but the wider point my point I
said I want a source I want see we're
arguing about here you're not contesting
that babies were killed no I'm saying I
want to see the evidence so why why are
you picking on the semantics of the
verasity one picture which has been
verified by British journalists why are
you picking on that journalist some
example some this wasn't as bad as it
seems British journalists are not an
academic Authority you know that full
well you've been fired because from
Daily Mirror for that very purpose what
I'm saying to you is this putting this
issue to the site I think you're trying
to use as a red herring to to move away
from the B what red herring this is a
red herring because already 1000 23
children have been killed in Gaza that's
why and you didn't ask the Ambassador
that question I literally asked the
Ambassador I said 3,000 people have
already been killed in a week in Gaza
well you didn't ask her you listen to my
interview with the listen I did listen
but excuse me put words in my mouth or
say I didn't ask a question hold let me
ask a question do you condemn the
killing of those children by the IDF I
tell you what I condemn I yes or no I'm
gonna answer your question honestly and
truthfully sure and I because I've
tweeted about this right okay I think
that what happened on October the 7th
was one of the worst atrocities I have
ever had to read about or watch on
happens every day in Palestine why do
you care about it actually doesn't it
doesn't it does no the Israeli forces
I've got the stats for that Israeli
forces do not
go go check Muhammad Israeli forces
protective Edge Israeli forces don't go
into Gaza on one day and grab
grandmothers and kill babies in their
beds and rape and abuse women is there
any evidence of that there it's been
multiple reports in multiple mainstream
media Publications well you to sit here
deny everything no I'm not denying
anything you are no I accept that some
civilians have been killed I do accept
this and I and I already said you don't
believe any of the reports that women
were ra no I didn't say that I said that
it's still to do you think they were
raped no I don't know it's like the
Russell bran thing you said we don't
know in see the evidence so why did you
apply two different
standards when it's Israel we know
they're raped when it's BR you know your
no it's been reported by legitimate
newsour when it's Israel you know but
when it's Russ when it's Russell Brand
you don't know comparison between
Russell Brandon what's happened it's the
same thing it's rape
allegation why you why stuttering I'm
not stuttering you are stuttering you
don't have you're contesting every
single thing that I'm saying yeah I'm
say at the end 1300 people were brutally
people have been killed on the other
side abused 2,000 people have been
killed on other I said that to the
Ambassador okay but do you condemn that
yes or no I don't think so you refuse to
condemn no you do refuse to why you
putting words in my mouth cuz you're not
you're not condemning it are you what do
you want me to
condemn excellent what do I want you to
condemn I want you to condemn the fact
that the IDF knowing that it's more
probable than not pressing buttons from
the sky killing innocent civilians 1,000
of them children that that is a war
crime and that is not acceptable morally
just like you cond the other one is it
condemnable or I believe given the scale
of what Hamas did on October the 7th
Israel is entitled to kill children no
that's not what I said go ahead they're
entitled to defend themselves with Force
then the question becomes Muhammad there
interesting debate sure if as it seems
to me you believe too go on Hamas are
not a Force for good do you believe that
well I think that anybody who kills
children and those elements of Hamas
were killing children right so we can
agree so we agree so my point is if
Israel's purpose is to rid the world of
Hamas after the atrocity of October the
7th sure how do they do that given that
Hamas embeds itself in civilian areas in
the way that it does everyone knows that
in Gaza how do they do that in the
surgically clean way that you seem to
think they should be doing okay can I
how do you not kill Civ I don't like any
civilian death mind I don't endorse any
civilian death condemn it though hang on
yeah no and here's why because I support
Israel's right to defend itself can I
say something no one more Point can
reply sure but the question then becomes
what is proportionate okay what is a
proportionate response I don't have the
answer because I don't know what a
proportionate response to 1300 murders
is when 260 young people at a music
festival most of them peace loving
people enjoying themselves at a festival
when they get slaughtered by people par
with machine guns I don't know what the
proportionate response is let me respon
so can you tell me you've spoken for
about two minutes you didn't do that
with the Ambassador by the way I'm just
showing you you're saying fair but but
you're not being fair so let me just let
me paint be fair sure I'm genuinely
interested in what you have to say
excellent you're you're from Irish
descent you know that there was an IRA
yes in Belfast and so on okay so let me
ask you a question now if there was IR
Ira in Belfast and they were occupying
Council properties and so on and then we
have a plane of RAF going to destroy
that Council of property destroy all of
Belfast flatten it as one representative
said got live the IDF said that um one
of the IDF members said that we will
flatten it completely that's what we
want to do we don't care about accuracy
he said we care about damage that's what
he said you didn't question her about
that but anyway if the RAF were to then
go into Belfast and D flatten as the IDF
and these guys want to do if they want
to flatten Belfast with all the white
people I'm going to use the term white
all the white people Council States
living in there with the excuse that
we're doing it because it's proportion
proportionate uh defense to uh the
terrorist what would you say about that
here's what I would say to you is that
acceptable or unacceptable here's what I
would say to you yeah the IRA committed
a series of atrocities over numerous
decades they targeted in their eyes
military and political targets they
usually gave some form of warning not
always okay they they were terrorists no
no they were terrorists sure they never
ever went out one day and committed the
barbaric Slaughter of 1 no no if they
did if they did sorry it's not if they
no Muhammad his wife's not irrelevant
they they never did but if they did
would you accept
by the way there were outrages committed
by by the lawyer Lawless parament to my
question is if they did would you think
it's accept they never came close to
committing an outrage on that scale if
they did is it acceptable they never
went in and kidnapped grandmothers or
kill babies in is it acceptable or not
they believe they were fighting for
better or worse and I believe for worse
and that's why I'm glad peace was found
they believe they were figh political
and Military Target I'm trying to bring
it closer to home to you're trying to
compare apples and no I'm not yes you
are it's you that's doing that the the
only comparison that I would say that we
saw from October the 7th and what Hamas
did is with Isis excuse me the only
comparison mind let me ask a question
let me ask a question a Palestinian and
Isis were taken out by the way with no
no here my you didn't do this with the
Ambassador which you gave the show to
him no no hang on I'm giving you plenty
of time no you're not giving you plent
you asked about the analogy of a plane
flying over targeting but you didn't
answer my question but that did happen
Muhammad with ISIS would you accept
Belfast to be flattened or not yes wait
a minute it never happens so the like
for like isn't it's a hypothesis
hypothetic not it's not I don't do
hypotheticals let's you don't do
hypothetical no no let's deal with
reality okay let's deal with reality let
me let me finish then you can ask you
don't ask a question no here's the
reality British public can see this
here's the reality right let's just
briti public can see this yeah they can
see it yeah go they're listen to the
debate keep going right I for what it's
worth I think it's a good debate to have
right these are questions many people on
the pro Palestinian side are having I
get it I get it right but you're trying
to compare what happened on October 7th
with the IRA no I'm not comp compar wait
a minute M I'm comparing it to Isis and
the way that the world in the end dealt
with Isis actually was to use air
strikes and many civilians were killed a
huge differ inoc people died not you
don't understand it because you have no
idea of the religious what's the
difference between what happened on
October the 7th and Isis the difference
between the Palestinian resistance is
the following okay any kind of thing
which has Palestinian resistance
attached to it and Isis which is as a
brand of tech theism okay is that Isis
is just one of many brands of tech fism
which you don't know what it is which is
a kind of excommunication type um
heresiological Islamic sect okay so if
there's it's nihilistic mass murder
that's all they care about listen I know
what you're saying but I'm saying
something else you agree with me don't
you I do but I of course I do but I'm
you're not understanding what I'm saying
so I'm trying to break it I am
understanding what you're saying what
I'm saying is that anything and I'm not
anti- Palestinian by the way sure
appears but over the many years you B if
you bothered to check what I said about
it I've always tried to shine a light on
the pl of the palestin allow me to speak
please because you're just talking over
me the difference between the two are
the following right even if we assume
that the killing of combatants in most
definitions of terrorism is something
which is bring someone to be a terrorist
okay I would say that if that is the
case then the state of Israel breaks
that threshold and meets that condition
because Israel is why is Israel not a
state terrorist if if their highest
officials are admitting that we want to
damage and we want damage and not
accuracy why answer me this question why
is the state of Israel who are illegally
occupying illegally occupying Gaza and
the West Bank according to international
law and even the icj said that okay
which is as you know an organ of the of
the UN all right so this is
international
law they're occupying they're seizing
they're bombarding they're
indiscriminately killing and they're
blocking the supply lines they're using
white phosphorus they're doing what what
you call mowing the grass which is every
couple of years every few years they're
killing the Palestinian people why I
want to understand what differentiates
an Israeli in the sky pressing a button
killing the civilians from somebody in
any terrorist organization shooting the
people what differenti it Israel will
say it has a right to defend itself so
will the terrorists that's what said and
they will that's exactly AR no it's not
though Terror h i ham his Hamas aren't
defending themselves Bin Laden wasn't
defending defense Bin Laden was trying
kill as many of the enemy as possible
let me ask a question how could it be
that an occupier is defending itself in
the first place the the the notion that
Israel is defending itself is as absurd
as the notion that the rapist is
defending itself from the victim because
Israel is the occupier you Haven hold
hold on let me finish just let me finish
an occupier by international law
definition means that they are already
in an offensive posture if they're in an
offensive posture if someone brings you
to P Morgan grabs you by the thing
throws you into your bathroom yeah
you're in your bathroom you're screaming
and they're eating food having a good
time one day you come out of your
bathroom you try and fight one of them
you try who's defending who from who
Muhammad who self-de how can you
self-defend when you're occupying me
this question let me speak but answer
the question let me speak answer the
question first fine I'm going to speak
yeah let me answer yeah I do I believe
that Israel's made a number of bad
choices that's not answer my question
wait I'm telling you what I think you're
not answer my question telling you what
I think go ahead okay I don't think
Israel's been perfect at all right you
the moral High Ground I think a lot of
the decisions Israel's taken are wrong I
think Benjamin Netanyahu by the way his
attempts to usurp the power of the
Supreme Court Mr year in Israel has been
a complete disaster you condemn them
from killing civilians or not I do not I
will defend them this week wait I will
defend them this week in defending
themselves against one of the worst
Terror attacks ever so you can kill
civilians for that you you can Target
Hamas can you target no hold on H if
Hass the controlling Gover ruling body
Gaza hi this is a false members of the
public this you're talking about
fallacies this is called the mort and
Bailey fallacy which is that you're
trying to defend one controversial idea
by using another it's m and Bailey
fallacy you can check out in your own
time the point is this I'm not asking
you whether Israel has a right to defend
itself we've already said the impos The
Logical and legal impossibility The
Logical and legal impossibility of an
occupying power according to
international law of actually defending
itself because already let me finish let
me finish it's already in an offensive
posture now I'm saying this if it is the
case you're just saying it's defending
itself against Hamas is the only way to
defend itself against Hamas by dropping
bombs in the most densely populated area
one of the most densely populated areas
in the world is that the only way it's a
false dyot you're creating a false they
can do surgic they can do I have they
can do they can go in and they can
Target we're going to take a short break
I actually I'm going to keep you here I
want to finish this I want to give you
the time I think it's an important
debate an important conversation but you
have to answer my questions I will we'll
come back yeah but actually you have to
answer mine it's my show actually I just
I can answer for the record you can ask
me as many questions you want but I'll
tell you what I think I've answered all
your question take a short break we're
going to come back and we're going to
finish with a few more minutes
okay welcome back to P says well
Muhammad hijab is still with me mamad
we've had look we've had a lively debate
I knew it would be debate this is a very
uh important issue it's a very it's a
passionate issue people on both sides
you know if I tweet about anything
doesn't matter what I say one side if
I'm even remotely sympathetic to them
the other side poor abuse and vice versa
and so on let's try and cut through it
all and get to what happens here how do
we find peace in the Middle East I've
been covering Israel Palestine since
I've been a journalist three decades and
it seems to me we're as far away now as
we've ever been how do you think get
you'll be surprised look H even Hamas
some four or five years ago they even
agreed to the 1967 lines the borders and
what what you have to understand that
this cannot be scapegoated on Hamas
because before hamas's existence this
was still going on this was going on
before Israel's existence but do you
believe in a in a two-state solution no
I I believe in look even Hamas was
proposing a two-state but do you believe
in it look there's advantages and
disadvantages this a different I don't
know I mean it's it's a difficult one
I'll be hon could you imagine two states
next to each other living in peace
Palestine Israel look it's a possibility
I mean as I say even Hamas was saying
that that's a possibility I mean this
was four years ago but what I want to
bring to your attention is that nothing
can happen if the international body or
the UN becomes a toothless agency in
2018 to 19 when actually 221 people were
killed on a peaceful protest in Gaza it
was called the Great March of Gaza 220
people died Hamas didn't shoot a bullet
uh no rocket was la launched yeah so 220
people died and this is um Nar even
mentioned by the UN and these kind of
agencies they tried to bring it up the
Palestinian Authority to they tried to
bring this up to the what you call the
icj which is part of the UN okay what
happened is the Donald Trump
Administration they tho they threatened
to freeze the assets of the icj which
which tells you the following what are
the Palestinian people to do because the
fact of the matter is if they try and
bring it up let me ask you let me ask
let finish the point if they try let me
finish the point if they're trying and
bring it up we're running out of time
why I'm jumping well if they're trying
and bring it up to international law
it's it's thwarted I do think
internation international law matters
sure I just don't believe that any peace
can be achieved with Hamas in charge do
you before Hamas after what happened
last weekend before forget about last
weekend last weekend has can't forget
about last weekend no it's not before
last weekend before Hamas in 1987 this
was still going on but not on this scale
and worse no it wasn't as bad as this
what are you talking about what happened
on October that shows ignorance the
single worst assault on popular since
911 it was Yap was 2,600 people died by
the way 1973 that's false in one day in
one day I don't know about 600 people
died in one I've got to leave it there
we run out of time I gave you more time
than I planed to I hope you appreciate
that and I appreciate you coming
in